the gyro can experience and then um like
a month later he was on the run for rape
yeah he raped some woman and then he
escaped and then he was out so addicted
to jujitsu the story was that he started
training again with a fake name but he
was like this high level black belt
there's only that this especially back
then when this happened is like the
early 2000s there's only a certain
number of high-level black belts that
are running around right so he put on
this fake Brazilian name and started
training in like the Pacific Northwest
and then but he strangle in black belts
and everybody's like what the [ __ ] is
who is this guy some people a space is
someone took a picture of them they go
that guy's wanted for rape oh [ __ ] I
remember talking to him on these THC
pills being like like some there's some
wiring that's not correct oh [ __ ] yeah
damn duh that's in whoa yeah
THC pills and yeah the exposed things
yeah they do bro I didn't mushrooms in
it exposed a lot yeah yeah you just
wrote yeah yeah yep I [ __ ] with
mushrooms because that's what happens
with me when I was on mushrooms I was
able to see people's true intentions
yeah cuz being a rapper and [ __ ] like
that you know you'd be having to peel
back the layers layers and layers and
layers I was trying to peel my own
layers back just for my own Shore
personal every man I ended up yeah yep
and I ended up being like backstage
somewhere and I was like [ __ ] I was like
I'm around all these people and I really
see their true intentions and I was like
I see what crowd they are and it was
like I felt like I was separated you
know what I mean it was like I was on a
boat all the way out here and they were
wrong on all on an island partying and I
was like damn yeah I could see what's
going on over there but it was cool like
I do mushrooms every now and then I
don't [ __ ] with it all the time I
haven't done them in like three years
because they help you see [ __ ] like that
so it's like for me I'll take that
experience and I'll just live with it
yeah I don't need to keep going through
it over and over like you probably seen
that dude and was like oh [ __ ] now I
know people who are rapey
as soon as I see us I knew he was
dangerous
like he was a legitimately dangerous
person but not just say bro not just a
trained killer but he was dangerous like
the way he thought about things
oh that's why there's people I'd done
out there yeah yeah I mean you you you
you don't know until you experience it
and that was a mild experience compared
to most people's owners psychos out
there [ __ ] crazy mofo